maybe in dark
the only way that we were gonna defeat
the lead was from the inside
I will never forgive you ever does that
mean we're enemies once more that
depends on what you do with your end of
the bargain kneel before Rafe al Ghul
even without me Starling still has
heroes to watch over it I want to be
with you
can I say something strange I'm happy
you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my arrow season 4 promo
breakdown they did something a little
bit different from the flash the flesh
did some voiceover on old footage it
took to make like a promo for season 2
arrow kind of did like the WWE intro
with Stephen Amell so for those that are
wondering it's going to be just like
last year with the the couple months
jump between the end of season 2 in the
beginning of season 3 if you if you
remember that was basically just Oliver
kicking ass in Starling city riding high
before it got his ass handed to him this
year's a little bit different because
the cast is fractured but but
essentially the same thing is going to
happen he's off with Felicity in Coast
City just living the life like trying to
figure out who the hell he is he's left
the arrow identity behind but whenever
he came out on stage at comic-con he was
wearing his green arrow outfit he said
it was like a practice round for a WWE
intro he's gonna be fighting or you know
maybe not fighting but doing something
with Stardust at SummerSlam later this
year i'm not a huge wrestling fan but
that does sound like a lot of fun but
but basically whatever ends up happening
in this first episode of his encounter
with damien dark is going to cause him
to put on that green arrow so that's its
gonna be like the impetus for him to
become green arrow because when we meet
him for the first time he won't be the
green arrow and he won't be the arrow
he'll still be Oliver Queen so something
is going to have to like shock him and
say okay I need to evolve the costume
itself looks a little bit closer to the
comics he has like he has the pauldrons
it's just like a little bit more armor a
little bit more tech what I'm hoping is
is that you know because the legends of
tomorrow characters are crossing over
with air in the flash that he'll get
some tech from STAR Labs and from Ray
Palmer like everyone will collaborate to
make him a better suit Stephen Amell
kept referring to quote-unquote his team
so I you know I think Oliver is getting
used to the fact that he's working with
a bunch of people and learns to rely on
them more that was this whole big thing
at the end of last season is that when I
started this I never planned for it to
turn into this big thing the showrunner
Marc Guggenheim was on hand and just
said that the suit represents who he's
going to become and it represents a
change in the tone of the show you know
I mean it's not turning into a comedy or
anything but he will be more like the
quippy you know joke telling Oliver of
the comics so if you've been saying like
this whole time that you want arrow to
be more like the comics then I think
you're going to like season for a little
bit more they announced a couple new
characters the biggest one italy at
least in my mind because we already knew
damian dark was coming so i don't
consider him a new character is mr.
terrific he's gonna be a good guy he'll
be working with felicity they didn't say
how the show is going to introduce him
but he will be the mister terrific of
the comics you know presumably in the
way that Ray Palmer became the atom so
I'm not expecting him to come on the
show in like his first moment he is like
a full-blown superhero you know probably
over the course of the season or at
least the course of the first half of
the season he will become mr. terrific
if you don't know who he is he's just
like another long time a-list member of
the Justice League in the context of the
DC Universe he's the third smartest
person on the planet because they name
dropped him when they were talking about
Felicity I think it's going to be like
the Ray Palmer situation where most of
his scenes happen with Felicity at you
know whatever Palmer tech is going to be
in the next season remember felicity is
the CEO now eventually the ideas is that
he will join team arrow and help them
fight Damien dark speaking of Damien
dark they announced another new villain
like like the small bad day me darks the
big villain on arrow but they said that
Anarchy would be working for him he's
another comic book character lesser but
just as much fun in terms of like you
know comic book integration with its
villains I think that they're gonna take
a few more liberties because Damien dark
for instance he was only around for an a
tissue run in Teen Titans that's
practically nothing and he had very
little to do with the League of
Assassins so they're gonna change a few
things and then they landed a really
good actor he's being played by neal
mcdonough you may not have seen him
recently but but he's a he's a great
actor it's gonna be a lot of fun I'd go
as far to say that the villain each
season on arrow defines what the story
is going to be when you have ratio goal
it's going to be a certain type of story
Damien dark flows from the same type of
energy and for those that are wondering
you know if he's hundreds of years old
why does he look so young Rachel goal
said that he stole waters from the
Lazarus Pit the whole ideas is that all
these shows like like the arrow flash
legends of tomorrow shows or becoming
more international so we're season one
was localized just to Starling city you
know we start to grow it slowly and
slowly season three was kind of
international I mean they did travel
around quite a bit it's just the show
building its universe out and on that
same coin is the League of Assassins
Malcolm Merlyn is coming back as racial
goal they didn't say that he would stay
racial goal for the entire season but
John Barrowman made this offhanded joke
on the arrow panel where he was like do
I get to keep wearing the racial goal
ring you know like the special ring that
Oliver gave him and the producer said
only as long as you continue to be
Rachel goal as if like there was a
ticking clock on that Nyssa was not at
the panel but she will be part of the
new season at least a small part moving
down the list Thea was confirmed his
speedy her costume is essentially just
just like the variation on Roy's costume
and Roy will be back it sounds like he
might even be back in the first couple
of episodes he is just a guest star
though Colton Haynes only had like a
one-year contract with the show so
whenever he comes back now it'll only be
for like one or two episodes at a time
based on what Stephen Amell has been
teasing it sounds like something happens
with thee in the first couple of
episodes like she turns a dark corner
and that's what brings Oliver back to
Starling city they did say that they
would explore the side effects of the
the resurrection from the Lazarus Pit
and this sounds like it's gonna flow
from that moving on to Diggle so really
cool he is confirmed to be getting like
like a helmet type face covering he'll
he'll have like a suit too but it's not
like a superhero suit it kind of looks
like the Black Canary leather jacket you
know it's not like you know bright green
it doesn't have a lot of like stuff
sticking off of it like Oliver's costume
you can choose to think of it as a super
suit but I'm just thinking of it as like
a face cover he's just like hiding his
identity the closest analogue in the
comics would be guardian so you could
say Diggle his guardian but he's not
going to have a shield and they're not
going to call him guardian they haven't
announced any other new characters yet
but they just started production this
week they literally just started
shooting footage the flash season 2 has
already started to make some casting
announcement so I'd expect arrow to
start announcing who they've cast as
some of these minor comic book
characters pretty soon to mr. terrific
will probably be the next one because
that's like that's a really big one he's
going to be around for the entire season
what about story details and crossovers
though so we know about the flavor out
crossover they're going to do the
episode 8 flash arrow you know big
crossover episode but they're also going
to be a two-part episode with all three
shows for legends of tomorrow they're
going to use one full episode on arrow
and one full episode on the flash to
tell this two-part story that will lead
up to the first episode of legends of
tomorrow they didn't say where that was
going to land right now it sounds like
it might end up being the mid-season
finale
both shows just just because like the
next episode after that would be the
first episode of legends of tomorrow but
but remember that's like before winter
break typically what happens is the
mid-season finale for arrow and the
flash falls it like the beginning of
december then the show goes on break for
about six weeks then it comes back when
it does legends of tomorrow will
premiere that'll be like the third week
in January so it just it sounds like
episode 9 of the flash and arrow will be
that two-part legends of tomorrow
episode that doesn't mean that that's
going to be the only time that we see
legends of tomorrow characters show up
on air in the flash it just means that
that like that two-part episode will be
fully dedicated to that cast and setting
up what's going to be going on on the
spin-off show the legends cast was there
they did confirm hawk man but I'm gonna
do like a separate legends of tomorrow
video where I'll explain what they said
and what they've been saying about the
show based on the way you guys reacted
to different things on air on the flash
I can already tell that you're really
gonna dig legends of tomorrow I mean
it's gonna be a while before we see it
but they will start releasing more
trailers as they start to shoot episodes
the funny thing about the legends cast
that's different from the arrow and the
flash cast is that the air on the flash
people have already read the first
couple of scripts for their episodes the
legends of tomorrow people haven't shot
the pilot yet but the only other really
big arrow details of note like things
that will inform the storyline or that
Felicity will essentially be in control
financially so everyone always asks
where Oliver gets money for all of his
toys all of Aztec this year it sounds
like it's going to be from Felicity like
he'll have to get her to sign off on
stuff and I actually I forgot to mention
it during my flash video but vixen is
coming up to at the end of August it's
only going to be six episodes it's gonna
premiere about the same time fear the
walking dead premieres I'll be doing
videos for that I'm gonna do a trailer
video in the next couple of days for
that too so be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's still at least like
like another three or four trailers that
I need to work through I have Star Wars
there's Warcraft there's a couple of the
things so if you guys want updates on
when all that stuff is going to post
just follow me on Twitter and Facebook
their links for that in the description
after I get through all that stuff I'm
gonna do character videos for some of
these new characters they've announced
like i'll do a mister terrific video
i'll do another day me and dark video
lots of really exciting stuff happening
i generally i think there's enough like
really awesome huge stuff to talk about
to get us to august and vixen and vic
then we'll get us to that October
premiere date for air on the flash so
while you guys wait for all that stuff
I've been doing like a bunch of trailer
videos this week you can click here for
Xmen apocalypse in like all the other
trailer videos that I've done is just
like it like a giant playlist you guys
can work your way down and you can click
here for my flash season 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight